yo this is another video request
some of
you guys asked me: "hey Daniel why do I
look better in the mirror than I look on
photos?". You're not alone, it happens to a
lot of people. So that's what we're going
to talk about in this video. Let's not
waste any more time let's get right into
it.
Hey if this is
your first time here on my channel
welcome! I'm Daniel consider
subscribing and also clicking that
notification bell, so you won't miss
any of the next videos.
So do you really look better in the
mirror than in photos? Yes and there's
four reasons for it, so let's start with
the first reason:
1. The mirror is a reflection so it's not
showing the real you, it's showing us a
kind of reverse. Think about it, you see
yourself every day in the mirror when
you brush your teeth, when you're getting
ready for school or work or for whatever reason.
So you get used to how you look like in
the mirror and over time you think that
that is normal. But it's not because it's
not the real you. So when you look at
yourself in a photo you see a flipped
version of yourself and immediately you
don't like it because it's the opposite of
what you're used to. So even though you
think you look better in the mirror
you're psychologically inclined to think
so because you're more used to it. That's
not the only reason...
The camera lens also plays a huge part
because you know they say that a photo
never lies right? But actually they do.
Because it can never show you the real
you. Not a hundred percent because of the lens, the angle and the light. Why do you
think so many people out there take so
many selfies from different angles
before ah they're finally happy with it. But the biggest problem is the lens and the
angle. Because of the distance and the
position between the camera and your
face, the lens can distort certain
features of your face making them look
larger or even smaller than they really
are. Alright let's try (test) the lens. So now
it's far away, right? That's where you
want it. If it comes close that just
creates a lot of ugh (problems) it looks bad. Now it's far away but I'm just gonna change
the angle of the camera look big
forehead...oh my goodness...
and then you go normal again
the other thing is the light, right? So
right now I'm in Japan and we're standing in
front of the window.
Check it out, hey Japan! So the light is
right behind the phone. That's
where you want it. If it's not, if it's
the other way around: Look at my face here, it's cloudy and it's still a
little bit dark but still my face look
kinda okay, right? Now look when I change
the angle... terrible just terrible...
Now another and one of the biggest
reasons why we look so different in
photos than in the mirror is because
when we look at ourselves in the mirror
you move, right? You check yourself from
different angles and so you keep on
moving. A picture is just a picture.
It's 2D it's not 3D. We see ourselves in 3D so it looks very different.
most experienced models know this
and that is why they look good in most photos by just
changing their pose a little
to get a better photo.
All right we are the
last one and the last reason is... YOU. Yes
you. Why? Well you know when you're alone
and you're watching yourself in a mirror
you are calm, you're relaxed, you're chilled.
So when you smile it looks very natural.
When you look certain ways and different
angles, it looks natural. But then when
you are with other people and they want
to take a photo and they say: "hey! Cheese!"
and you look and you see that camera...
you're like:
"oh no, it's a camera! I
already look bad in photos..." and then you
don't feel natural anymore. You don't feel
confident anymore and it shows in your
face and when they take that picture it's
like ...(pulls facial expressions).
Or you try to smile like... (Daniel shows uncomfortable smile).
You know what I'm talking about...
You get that facial expressions... and the photos
don't look good because of you.
So what can be done?
Are you just stuck? Will you just always
look bad in photos? Well no, there's a few
tips and tricks and I made a whole
dedicated video for you that you can
check out right here (Daniel points to the video) .
Now if you liked
the video give me a thumbs up subscribe
and I'll see you in the next video the
cheers